Richard Gere: …Nice…I’ve got new tea…I’m
really happy.
I’m sitting with my friend.
Film Courage: You both have the same month
birthdates which I find very interesting…August
31st?
Joseph Cedar: We do.
Richard Gere: Why did I know that?
Film Courage: Oh…you didn’t know that?
Joseph Cedar: I knew that.
Richard Gere: I didn’t know it?
You never told me that!
Joseph Cedar: August 31st.
Richard Gere: This is really bizarre.
This explains so much…because we’re not
really Virgos.
Film Courage: You’re not…you’re on the
cusp?
Richard Gere: Well I don’t really know what
the mix is but we’re not like a normal…he’s
more like a normal Virgo than I am.
Film Courage: Okay?
Joseph Cedar: I know nothing about that…but
I’m happy to share the birthdate…
Richard Gere: I didn’t know that?
Film Courage: I’m wondering if the two of
you are simpatico?
This was actually going to be my last question
but let’s do it now.
I mean…if you both have the same birthdate…there
must be some similar sensibilities or traits?
Maybe not?
I’m reading too much into this?
Joseph Cedar: …I think as far as this film
(NORMAN) goes…I’m Richard Gere’s inner
“Norman.”
So if there is an inner Norman in Richard
Gere, some of it is on this side of the shot.
Richard Gere: There is no question that the
8 or 9 months which we spent together, there
was a point where you had revealed your inner
Norman enough to me that I went “Aha!
That’s where I’m going with this.”
Joseph Cedar: But you know I do have to say,
just for the record (between us)…
Film Courage: Please… Joseph Cedar: I think
part of the fun of working with Norman is
that Norman goes further than what I ever
would.
So there might be something of Norman in me
but I hold it back.
In the movie, he just lets go.
Which is fun.
Richard Gere: It’s great fun.
Then you were also generous enough with me
that you allowed that inner Norman to emerge
and scream once and awhile so I could see
how far I could go with this.
Joseph Cedar: Right.
Film Courage: [For Joseph] Well I’m fascinated
by your take on watching Richard change into
this character.
This is not a normal character for Richard
to play.
He usually plays the alpha male.
Richard Gere: This is not a normal character
for anyone.
I mean this is a completely unique character
and for sure…I mean it’s a big distance
for me to play him and I think in reality
a big distance for anyone to play this guy.
He’s written a completely unique character.
Film Courage: How was it to watch him (Richard
Gere) transform in terms of body language,
the way he carried himself, his interactions
with others, his personal space?
Joseph Cedar: I think that the biggest satisfaction
that I have is when each scene has what the
scene is about, but then there is this little
nuance that has to do with what the character
is really going through and it usually has
to do with his…this motivation that he has
and no one else knows.
He’s trying to get close to someone.
He’s trying to introduce someone to someone.
It’s not the obvious thing.
And seeing Richard grab onto that small nuance
and bring it to life and express it in some
way was incredibly satisfying to me because
it was as if he was revealing this secret
about what really goes through Norman’s
head.
Richard Gere: I remember him (Joseph) directing
me…I’m flashing on one of the early scenes,
it’s actually the first scene that is in
the movie and I’m approaching Dan Stevens
in the park (Bill Kavish in NORMAN) and I’ve
got a [real estate] deal and I’m trying
to convince him.
I remember we were doing the shot where he
moves where he…no one wants anything to
do with this Norman or any “Norman.”
It’s…how do you make them stop without
losing your own dignity in making them stop?
And you see this a lot with the characters
in this movie who they don’t want to have
to say “Go away.
Leave me alone.”
It’s some level of “Please.
Enough!”
So [in the scene] I’m chasing…I’m chasing
and we’re doing a Steadicam shot and he’s
saying (I remember this direction was like)
“Maybe you can just kind of bob behind him
and try to get his attention while you’re
coming behind?”
and it was so…I mean I got it immediately
what you were talking about and that ended
up informing much of what I did in the film.
This sense of…
Joseph Cedar: Right…peaking over someone’s
shoulder and just waiving “I’m still here!”
is…seeing Richard Gere do that is incredibly
satisfying.
Film Courage: Great!
Thank you.
That’s excellent.
Thank you!